hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to the nightmare fishing
trip also holy [ __ ] this music is
amazing I'm too old for this [ __ ] I hurt
myself
I got damaged like if the trans-siberian
Orchestra and The Nightmare Before
Christmas had a baby anyway this game is
made by suits and nukes who's been
making a lot of really cool games lately
mostly to do with morbid and horrible
bloody death but that's what I like
that's that's how many like them so this
one's probably no different so if I had
to get oh but okay that was supposed to
happen yeah I was just falling through
the sky and landed in a river of blood
that seems like a perfectly normal
occurrence in the nightmare fishing
tournament like am I the bait is that
how this works am I the one that the
fish are gonna be eating a whole lot of
oh hi oh me to catch you up to speed
something tells you I'm not from around
here what do you mean you've got a pile
of corpses that look exactly like me in
your boat and I'm assuming that this is
now the River Styx which would uh you
see here is for sale although you won't
have much in the way of credits just yet
uh-huh all nightmare fishing tournament
is underway and the grand prize is
return to the land of the living the
living I'd like to enter you're going to
need a few things
huh I'll go ahead and provide you with
the very basics just Iran into Hulk from
there you're going to need to figure it
out on your own cool do stop by from
time to time
I'm always stocked with the very best in
weapons and items that is if the price
is right okay I didn't know that hell
ran on a monetary system but I'll do my
best to do whatever it takes to please
you if that is only money okay so we got
oh [ __ ]
panic shank stronger than the starter
blade the panic shake cuts deeper with
each stab causing greater damage that's
nice fires net that temporarily traps a
fish when a hooked fish is in stare the
gripmeter will not deplete when stabbing
it oh okay
ah that's not nice a camera that
attaches to the lure and sends a live
feed of the activity in the immediate
area it's only 100 let me look at the
other ones tracks fish to the position
where the Chum is placed that's nice an
oldie but goodie dropped the diving bell
underwater return to it and plena Chirac
oh oh that's an old-school device it was
literally like a heavy brass or metal
bell like a bell-shaped bell that they
would literally drop down in the ocean
it was heavy enough that it kept this
pocket of air inside and would stay
completely stationary as it goes down so
it'd be a pocket of air down deep under
the water so that people could breathe
then that that back when people didn't
understand preffer pressure just Revere
in truth and he exploded a lot there was
a lot of exploding going on underwater
okay so I have a thousand do I need [ __ ]
I do not ah apparently I got bait but
now I can't buy the diving bell panic
shank I like that when I need to stop
yeah haha okay anyway okay lure cam that
sounds good chum you can buy some of
that okay he's a pleasure I always like
to please the Grim Reaper that's my
favorite thing okay there's nothing
horrible thing okay oh I didn't read all
that okay stand here to drive the boat
oh that's cool hey come back
I want more stuff I'm gonna Rob you with
my panic shank I'm old stab ya oh he's
coming back ah didn't mean it sorry
grimmy oh you have fun with your pile of
bodies
oh man there's people falling in the
background where are these people coming
from is this what happens you get you
get dropped into a the southern bayou of
hell and you have to fish your way back
home okay stop riding boat with s okay
ah click the tackle box to open the
Bateman Oh Oh does anyone want a fresco
oh oh [ __ ]
presses boom oh oh hi okay uh uh pressed
up oh oh
swing down and battle it oh this is why
I needed the panic shank oh this is why
I need to stab a stabbed click on the
fish ball driving
whoa oh God Oh Oh what was that
what what are you pooping out green Oh
hearts collected are stored in the
inventory I'm sorry this is a lot of
information that I'm getting all at once
I have no idea what's happening you
knocked it down now swim look quickly oh
[ __ ] I'm oh I'm an idiot oh uh how do I
know
ah god damn it ah how do I uh [ __ ]
uh okay sweet I'm not goddamn time go
real like the wind ah [ __ ] [ __ ] do I
get it okay okay oh [ __ ]
well I've done goofed hey hey I'm old
ah that's not how this is [ __ ] secure
I'm supposed to stab you whoo holy [ __ ]
oh god damn it stop biting me
you [ __ ] we'll get you oh [ __ ] what's
happening I'm drowning maybe yeah oh I
have a breathe meter oh I need to
breathe okay all right let's try this
again
once more with feeling this time and
let's try to get from the back end so
that we can not die yeah that's right
get Steve get stabbed I'm gonna collect
all your fish eggs / blood globules okay
this time I'm not gonna waste time yeah
okay let's go all right I got this don't
worry about me okay
space this is sorry I'm I'm not I'm not
an expert at this I apologize but I
caught a fish right man this game is a
lot more involved than the other games
that suits and neuters made I like it
already it's a unique thing I mean I
haven't played many fishing games in my
time but this might be the best 100
that's he okay that's what I collected
okay I could probably sell those clicker
to candidio oh but I didn't get the
right fish okay so I need to there we go
I need to grab my boat here and try to
find the wrap flash I got some chum come
on Chum the water how is any fish Oh
how's any fish gonna be able to tell
what Chum is when the entire river is
blood I Clyde did you know you can swim
to the bottom I nearly drowned last time
I tried it but a guy can usually find a
a free bait if they know where to look
ah something tells me that I probably
shouldn't be diving down deep where the
fish is but I'm not gonna take your
fishing spot I'm gonna hang on let me
see what's over here oh look it's more
floating islands of blood that eternally
replenished their own supply if I could
reach those clams at the bottom I might
find a pearl Libra says if I collect
three of them I can craft them into a
double cash bonus that makes all the
fish I catch worth double now how the
hell does combining pearls together make
that happen
Jen came logic yeah I was just about to
say the same thing
gosh dang game logic and I I vaguely
remember those floating mountains of
blood from like the original doom do you
remember that when you ever look at the
background of the original doom and you
see those weird like things in the
distance and there was a lot of blood a
lot of mountains of blood
I tried shooting them okay
I'm not entirely sure what you mean by
that stumpy but considering your name is
stumpy and you just told me to go down
and fight fish mono e mono mono e fish
I don't think I'm gonna take your advice
about that one goodbye alright this
seems like a good enough spot
alright so bait ah who wants a nice who
wants who wants a fresh baby
Oh baby fish anybody oh yeah
okay what about Chum they do that No
hey let hey hey buddy oh I got him okay
so I need to swim down okay this is
gonna go well now this time I'm not
gonna get bit like an idiot I got bit
like an idiot
god dammit yo you use a sassy oh I got
you I got the panic tank baby okay so
I'm gonna collect your eggs call your
future children are gonna be mine that's
a horrible thing to say
oh well yeah yeah that's a gun as a
beggin right there that's an
award-winning beggin that's what I call
big one it's not what I needed Oh albino
B oh I know baby oh yes I picked the
baby as bait it's a baby here
it's an albino baby eater but it's still
a baby eater okay well that's good I
guess not really
I guess I'm purging the ocean of these
horrifying baby eating fish which is
awfully not nice okay can I just go oh
[ __ ] there we go
still not used to the controls it's very
finicky well it's not very finicky it's
just I don't know what they are so I
know other ones if I could reach this oh
shut up dude
Oh so there's recipes that I need here
ah ah okay okay so if I get a purple one
I'll get better lung capacity but I need
to hold on to these things
I'll keep like I'll keep like two of
each but I can sell them as how much
money okay all right whatever I'll
figure it out
don't mind me I'm just go fish I sure
love the fashion the nightmare I didn't
bait it Naumann idiot wait
Master about a nice jiggly worm anybody
want a worm hello oh it's creepy down
here in the dark depths I wouldn't want
to swim down here even though that's the
exact next thing I'm gonna do okay
so I'm looking for something it was like
uh like a brownish gray the deep grew
not you
ooh you're creepy hey hold off no no not
my worm that yeah you're the one you're
the one eat it yeah I got you huh go get
you don't buy me don't buy me don't mind
me don't mind me you Nick don't buy me
ah ah [ __ ] there we go come on stabia
have you oh you don't like this the
panic shank has all the power
yeah is that just your scales falling
off okay just two of them okay go uh
point okay and then reel them in then I
got my thing I needed it I got the exact
thing that I needed hello oh that's a
beggin that's a big one albino shovel
snout is mine I love the fanfare of
victory because I'm a victorious mother
Humber okay oh yeah I got the biggest
one a thousand credits rewarded holy
[ __ ] thank you you have five minutes to
catch the biggest one you can find oh
the blood bass are we starting now holy
[ __ ] I didn't even I don't
I mean I'll give you idea uh okay how
about right here's good enough
I don't stock don't dive in don't go
mano a fish Oh although I'll do that if
I need it uh just [ __ ] do the thing
okay there we go all right we got this
oh [ __ ] I'm running out of time gotta go
get a go get a girl get a go how do i
how do i Chum the water I don't know how
to Joe you're not the one you're weird
what is it with the one look like whoo
that was it that was it
eat it oh yeah okay okay okay okay okay
a little a little I got you whoa daddy
oh you're a toughie
oh not not so tough anymore I got two of
these here we go
real man Bob with the bobbin - Bobby -
Bobby - Bob with the bobbin the baba -
Baba - baba - Baba gave me that fish
give me that fresh - okay give it to me
give it to me give it to me give it give
it to me okay now since there's time
remaining in the round I'm gonna go find
my buddy reap II I don't have the right
cop I don't have the right combination
and close that [ __ ] okay okay let's see
ooh that sounds cool oh hell yeah
hello an explosive spear oh hell yeah oh
I'm gonna go mono official on you
bastards oh here we go
wanna get some I'm gonna get a I'm gonna
get in explode ease and then a standard
I probably I don't know how much I'm
gonna need okay all right let's let's
get the oh it gave me some basics I'm
gonna get the explode ease whoo we're
gonna go where oh my god this is awesome
oh this is awesome I gotta watch my
breath hey aah aah oh God
oh Jesus here [ __ ] God I died already
good God die holy [ __ ] that didn't work
at all what what didn't that work
I thought experiment was gonna be much
gonna you wanna fight with me bro huh
what's that
oh you can't you can't handle your
poison [ __ ] okay are you straight
ah [ __ ] Jesus die [ __ ] what
get back here WI you little [ __ ] oh
[ __ ] off it's impossible
you can't kill him like this that's so
stupid that's so stupid
what was the point I wasted all my money
here oh maybe you gotta like maybe you
gotta catch him first
I don't know no baby baby you gotta
catch your fish first I thought I could
like Stefan and drag it up to the top be
a total unbelievable badass coming out
of the surface of the water here man
just have it in my teeth rising
delicately through the waters but alas
I'm an [ __ ] a little bit a little I'm
on you oh no oh no oh no is somewhat wow
you're really done yeah it's good thing
I got the unbelievable clicking skills
of a god yeah
I've been training this finger for years
alright pretty easy for me I'm a Jew
soulless one - nice nice alright I'm
just gonna get to the end of this round
and then see where it goes from there I
think I vaguely remember there being
like oh oh no oh I've failed I'm the
worst
god damn it I should have tried harder
okay so that is nightmare fishing
tournament you can play this game for
yourself through the link in the
description below it's actually really
interesting I've never really played a
fishing game before and it's such a
unique concept that I actually really
like it so let me know what you think
down the comments below thank you
everybody for watching and as always I
will see you in the next video bye bye